hi there today we're looking at vertex
learning visual representations from
textual annotations by Karen Desai and
Justin Johnson of the University of
Michigan so this paper at its core is
pretty simple
on high-level it proposes to take the
task of image captioning which is where
you're given an image and you're asked
to produce a caption for the image and
basically train a model to do this and
then just take the visual part of it as
a baseline to transfer learn on other
visual tasks and that appears to works
work surprisingly well if you don't have
much data so if you if you don't have
much data to pre train on this appears
to work very well alright
as always if you like content like this
then consider sharing it out subscribing
to the channel or tell me what you think
in the comments so as I already said the
the idea here is pretty simple so people
have been looking for pre training tasks
for visual tasks so a visual task is
anything where the input is an image and
then you usually have some sort of
neural network that processes the image
and then at the end you can have many
things so you can have a classifier that
classifies the image into one of many
classes if you know imagenet that's a
thing so if there's a cat here then the
the imagenet classifier here would say
cat or you could have something like a
object detector that tries to predict on
the image where the cat is like where
the bounding box you could have a you
could have a semantic segmentation where
it's like all of these pixels here are
cat and maybe all of these pixels here
are sky and so it labels every pic so
there's many visual tasks that you can
formulate and they all sort of share the
same architecture and specifically they
all share this part right here the if
you will this is the visual and
it's usually a convolutional neural
network and what's really different
between the tasks is mostly this last
part here that does the actual task but
this end is often called the backbone so
this is the backbone and the idea now is
if I have a bunch of these tasks
sometimes I don't have money labels for
these tasks I don't have many labeled
images so that I could train this big
architecture from scratch like in
medical images or just in domains where
you don't have many images so couldn't I
somehow come up with a method to create
this backbone beforehand so to create
the backbone given another data set and
the simplest variant here is you take a
big image data set such as image net and
then you train a classifier like we said
to predict some classes on it and then
because an image net has a lot of images
then this is your backbone and then
whenever you have a different task you
simply take the backbone transfer it
over and then train the other basically
you continue training on the other tasks
that's called transfer learning the
question is how do you get a good
backbone so if you train on something
like image net then this is of course a
supervised tasks you have a very good
learning signal but even image net has
like 1 million images but for example
the Internet has many more images so
what you could do is you could train on
this much bigger data set that you
collected from the internet so let's
just call it Internet but there you
don't have labels right so what you'll
have to resort to is instead of
supervised learning is self supervised
learning where you have an image and
maybe you rotate it to the right so here
is our cat it rotated to the right and
then you have a classifier that predicts
that these this image was rotated to the
right and then that will become your
backbone these self supervised methods
they work very well there is a different
number of them for example moko things
like this and there is also a number of
techniques that do supervised pre
training
and then transfer learning you can maybe
watch my video on big transfer which is
a very large attempt to do to pre train
a backbone for visual tasks all right
now you can see right here that the sort
of direction is that the more data the
better so that's sort of the idea here
that image net is a big data set we can
train a really good backbone but you
know the Internet is an even bigger data
set we don't have labels so there's a
trade-off but we potentially can train
an even better visual backbone to then
transfer learn with this paper goes into
a different direction they say look if
you go in this direction right here you
get more images but you get less
information per image so with image net
at least you have the label right per
image but if you simply take a photo of
the Internet you don't even have to
label you have to resort to self
supervise what if we go into the other
direction and we look for images that
have very high quality annotations but
maybe we don't have as many can we can
we do the same thing can we learn good
back bones by trading off quality for
quantity in this case in their quantity
and quality trade-off is they go for
descriptions so they'll go for something
like this where you'll have an image and
you'll have a caption for the image and
so they show these on a line here
semantically dense semantically sparse
but their task is going to be caption
generation so they're back they're more
their task is given an image I want to
produce a caption and there are data
sets that you can train this from in a
supervised fashion which of course these
are very expensive to create I mean if
you want to create an image net data set
then you have to label each image but if
you want to create a caption data set
that's even harder because human really
needs to sit down look at the image and
an image net everything is like one
class but here you need to look at the
image
and then you'll have to come up with
like an adequate description here the
adequate description is an orange or an
orange and white and orange and white
cat near a plate and the white cake okay
so that's that's the caption right here
and of course the caption is ambiguous
so you'll have to collect multiple
captions per image and you let have to
make sure that the humans that do this
do a good job and so on so this these
are very very expensive datasets but
they are very high quality if you think
of what does what does a single label
let's just take image that image that
has a single label per class let's say
this is cat or cake for that matter it
just sort of gives you very few bits of
information but if you consider the text
here an orange cat and a white cat an
orange and white cat you know that there
is a cat right you know that it's one
cat you know what its color is orange
and white then you know that there is a
white cake right so do you know the
other object and you know the relation
they are near each other okay same for
here a brown and white puppy so this is
one object and the description of the
object there is a there are apples there
is a green lawn and you the relations
between them are also clear and the
puppy is lying on the green lawn and
looking at the apples so the information
in captions is so much more dense than
just labels and that's the that's the
back drop here to say hey can't we can't
we do can't we
pre-trained a backbone from maybe a
small data set but that has so much
information like a caption data image
caption data set okay so their method is
nothing more they train image captioning
and then they use the visual backbone
for transfer learning so this is the
model there's an image the image goes
into this visual backbone right here
which is a ResNet 50 so this is a very
very standard convolutional neural
network and
that gives you these features so these
features are 7 by 7 by 2048 this is the
standard output of a ResNet 50 and then
from this part on they do a linear
projection such that they can now input
it into a language model okay so they
have visual features and now they feed
those into the language model and the
language model is just a transformer
actually 2 transformers so one
transformer they're both autoregressive
one transformer tries to predict the
caption in a forward way and the other
transformer tries to predict the caption
in a backward way that's down here so in
this direction is backward because the
caption has been reversed if you don't
know what a transformer is I've made
several videos on transformers the first
one is attention is all you need and
that's sort of the same the same kind of
transformer they use here so as you can
see right here you have this multi-head
attention the layer normalization
attention from the decoder now the
difference between the original Vaswani
attention is all you need transformer
and this one is that in the original
transformer you had for example if you
had a machine translation task you would
have the French maybe a French sentence
over here and then you would have the
beginnings of German sentence here right
this is what you have already produced
and now you're asking what should the
next word be and the architecture was
such that there is a decoder transformer
right here and that there is an encoder
transformer that encodes whatever you
already had and then at some point there
is this cross attention right there is
the signal from the decoder going into
the encoder and the encoder
incorporating that and then at the end
right here the encoder would predict or
the entire transformer would predict
what the next word will be the only
difference right here is that the decode
this sorry I mix this up this
the decoder this is the encoder the only
difference right here is that this
encoder is no longer a transformer but
is this ResNet this ResNet 50 okay
because now you don't have an image as a
you can think of it like a translation
task you want to translate from images
to text okay so your input is going to
be an image and the signal is going like
it would go in the original transformer
into the decoder it would come from the
image so from these visual features goes
here
so in this drawing this thing is going
in here and then you simply predict the
next word and you do it in both
directions and the the reason you can do
it in both directions here this wasn't
is not the case of course if you have a
a decoder like a standard transformer
task because you don't need to do
inference at this you just need to do
training and training you can do using
teacher forcing and so you can do this
in a bi-directional way you don't need
you don't need this at inference time
so at inference time you simply cut off
this part right here
that's your visual backbone okay and
these features here those are going to
be the features that you then train your
task on and sometimes you fine-tune this
or sometimes you keep it frozen you can
choose that all right so red
convolutional network to encode the
images that gives you features visual
features those visual features go into
two transformers both try to predict the
caption of the image one in a forward
motion one in a backward motion and you
train it to predict as accurately as
possible the gold-standard captions that
you have in your data set that's it if
you train this model well that means the
model can produce accurate captions for
these images which means that it has
learned something meaningful about the
image to the degree of course that the
original caption that was in here
dataset was a good descriptive caption
but we're just we're going to assume
that in these data sets this is the case
all right that's what they do now
interesting thing here is that in their
standard in their standard in their
standard set up they only have one of
these transformer layers so of these
things right here they only have one and
that's like I think it's like 2,000
units wide but or sorry the hidden
dimension is 2,000 units or 2048 but
they only have one layer so what that
means is that this transformer is not
very powerful
so most that you force most of the power
to come from the visual encoder the
visual encoder head basically has to do
most of the work and then the the
transformer is going to simply be a very
shallow language model on top of that
and that of course makes your visual
backbone even better all right we can
pretty much skip the rest that's the
idea like that there's nothing more to
it you train this from the beginning you
don't use any pre-trained whatever you
train this from scratch and then you use
this and in the first experiment they
simply train a linear classifier on top
of that representation so they freeze
the backbone and then they use a linear
classifier and they compare this two
base lines so one of the baseline is
imagenet supervised where you use the
same backbone but you train it on
imagenet in a supervised fashion okay
and then you use that backbone to
transfer out of the racks it's kind of
like what big transfer does but just on
the regular 1000 class imagenet baseline
then you have the sort of the
unsupervised pre-training ones so mochou
so per this parallelism and we're going
to purl
but mochou is this momentum contrast
which is one of these supervised methods
that has been shown to work really
really well and this is also mocha en is
trained on image
but now without the labels because moko
is unsupervised and moko cocoa is
trained on the cocoa dataset and the
cocoa dataset is what this paper here
the vertex paper uses cocoa is this
image captioning data set now what's
important to note is that cocoa has
about 10% only of the images of imagenet
so it's considerably smaller now let's
see how these things fair right here you
can see on the x-axis the number of
images okay the number of images that
the data set are that the pre-training
method trains on now of course some of
these are going to be capped because for
some datasets there are just not more
images available right so they're going
to be capped here the ones that are
training on coke on the ones that are
training on imagenet are going to be
capped here you can already see that the
vertex outperforms the image net
supervised baseline by pretty much when
you only give it this many images okay
so the way you do it is in this case you
simply train these models now the brown
one is when you take one caption per
image but the data set actually has more
more than one caption per image so when
you use more than one you can still post
boost your performance a bit and that
works way better then when you do this
supervised free training on image net
which would get you here with about the
same amount of images now when you use
all of image net you can see here you
can get to a similar performance right
here but you have to use a ten times
bigger data set to get there alright so
this already shows you sort of the
advantage here now also consider the
difference to the unsupervised ones so
if you look at the same amount of images
the unsupervised basslines or even lower
but if you
go to more images they sort of get
closer to imagenet and in their own
papers there are there are some evidence
that if you self supervise to train for
long enough you can actually surpass
imagenet supervise pre-training but I'm
not so sure that that's really the case
but you can see here the trade-off
between higher quality information but
smaller data sets versus lower quality
information but more data per data set
and yeah if I guess if you were to if
you were to pre train these self
supervised methods with lots more data
in a self supervised manner they would
maybe end up even higher than imagenet
now this graph here is sort of the same
thing where they also train a linear
classifier and you can see right here
that now the image net supervised
baseline is outperforming vertex by a
lot so what's happening here now this
here is actually this is on image net so
the task here that you transfer learn is
image net here it was like a neutral
task pass Calvillo see none of these
methods have trained on Pascal they
simply have trained on their own data
set these have trained on Coco this has
trained on image net and then they have
transfer learned to Pascal now the task
is actually the transfer learning task
is image net so naturally the the thing
that was pre trained in a supervised
fashion on image net is going to have a
huge advantage in this task because it
basically has already learned the task
beforehand whereas the vertex
it has pre trained on Coco not on image
net and you can see if you give it the
same amount of images for pre training
it can actually it's it's fairly close
to the image net baseline so that's
pretty respectable right there
now again of course if you use more
images on the same data set that you
then train for then of course the the
image net baselines
to outperform it but so pretty cool to
see here that in this smaller image
regime and also consider this down here
if you go even an order of magnitude
lower it's really shining that if you
have higher quality information and you
make use of it you don't need as many
images and now we knew this for a long
time but this now is showing the same
for transfer learning for visual
transfer learning so this was when we
froze the backbone and then we trained a
linear classifier on top they go and
they make a short excursion here and
show how different parts of their model
affect their final performance and they
find that for example the by captioning
which I believe is the is forward and
backward captioning significantly helps
for example compared to only forward
captioning and they also find that it's
significantly outperformed other pre
training tasks that they can do and they
also investigate whether how big their
models should be so here this is their
baseline model so I was I was wrong
actually they the it's one layer of with
1024 you can see as you make the layer
bigger and bigger that generally helps
but I guess they decided against it
because the gains are too little to to
afford to make it worth and also if you
make the network deeper here he make the
transformer have more layers the
performance goes up but again the gains
are marginal so I guess they're gonna
leave it away so their baseline as you
can see is these resonate 50 with the
one layer of 1024 size so this is now
the last task
it's the fine-tuning task so this is
what most people would do is they would
try
a backbone and then it would fine-tune
it on a different data set on or on a
different task where they don't have
much labels and here the situation looks
a bit different so if you look at for
example a task on Koko
so there are several tasks on Koko one
of them is image captioning which they
use for parade trip for pre-training if
you do other tasks on Koko you can see
right here that compared to the
supervised baseline this vertex it
performs about the same or maybe a bit
worse but what you can see is it
performs significantly better than for
example moko that was only trained on
Koko so again this shows that if you
have the same data set higher quality
information makes it worth it and it's
even better as you can see on moko that
was trained on image net it's just not
quite as good as the supervised baseline
but all of them of course are better
than just a randomly initialized Network
that is trained from scratch I mean
that's the entire point of transfer
learning that you are better than simply
learning from scratch and this shows
throughout this experiment except in
this LV is masking tasks where they do
outperform the other the other things
the other methods significantly now the
lower numbers on this tasks tasks also
means that the task is harder than these
tasks right here and therefore there are
more gains to be made and therefore you
could hypothesize that the bigger the
more quality information that you input
can be used in a better way so maybe
more complex also the more complex the
task is might also have an influence on
how well the transfer learning works if
you come from a high quality transfer
learning task versus a low quality
transfer learning tasks yeah so the
lastly compared here with
again with Pascal vs the object
detection and these I naturalist
classification where I believe this is
also a transfer learning task with fine
tuning and as you can see they can also
hold up against the supervised baseline
or even outperform it at sometimes the
green triangles mean that they
outperform it by a significant margin
but then on this task right here they
again lag behind so I think the point of
the paper isn't really to show that that
this is the best thing ever but the
point of the paper is to show that you
can go about pre trainings basically the
the common assumption is that you need
more and more and more and more data for
your model to learn about the data set
and they conclude here no actually you
can do with with very few data points as
long as they have high quality
annotations okay so I think that's the
point of the of the paper and they don't
always outperform the other baselines
and whatnot but they keep they keep the
performance the same which basically
means that this is an option here is a
pretty cool result where they visualize
the attention of their image captioning
model because they train an image
captioning model and you can really see
that the image captioning model learns
something meaningful about the image so
when it's a bird flying the attention is
mainly on the bird as you can see then
over the the attention widens out over
the image air so over the air the
attention is here in the sky and on the
on the ocean and then it goes near the
ocean and then the attention is on the
ocean itself as you can see so they have
a bunch of these images and they're
they're pretty cool here a dog so
focused on the dog riding on and then
you can see the attention going down
because on is riding on means probably
there's something below the dog
a surfboard now the attention is fully
on the surfboard in so as soon as you
say in the attention as you can see it
widens out so I think that's that's
fairly cool fairly cool demonstration
that the model understands sort of the
the in relation namely if it is focused
on something and that something is in
something else then it widens the
attention out to see what it is in OK
the ocean and then it focuses the
attention on the ocean so that's that's
a pretty that's a pretty cool result I
guess we already knew this because we
could train image captioning models
before it's just to show that it
actually makes sense to use them as a
pre training task for backbones now
what's the future of this the authors
here in their introduction they make a
claim that this has a good future
because they here they only train on
this small data set right it's it's
smaller than image net as you can see
here and they already get same
performance as if you train on the whole
image net data set in a supervised
fashion of course they're also
supervised but they have 10 times less
images and they they say something to
the effect of you do you know it would
be pretty easy to collect more data for
this task because the internet is full
of images and mostly these images have
like some text with them they you know
they have these descriptions or they
have text around it people write
something about the images you could
like mine Twitter and then their
responses when someone posts an image
might tell you something about the image
but this definitely counteracts their
this definitely counteracts their notion
that these are very high quality labels
right their entire point here was that
these annotations these these datasets
with these these image caption data sets
like cocoa they have very very high
quality annotations so this this text
here is very high quality it's really a
descriptive text of the image that tries
to capture what
human can see visually in the image and
as soon as you go out to the internet
and collects a text around images that's
not going to be the case that
information is again going to be quite
low quality and so I doubt that the
performance here would hold up or that
the claim you can easily you know you
can easily create more data for this
task holds up so that's a bit my worry
about the future of this but it's
definitely cool and definitely shows
these quality quantity trade off very
well alright that was my two cents to
the paper I invite you to read it and
tell me in the comments what you think
about it and I'll see you next time